[Applaudissements]
chacun de nous connaît une personne qui
n'aime pas son travail
si vous pouvez pas penser à quelqu'un
c'est peut-être que c'est vous beaucoup
d'entre nous n'aime pas ce qu'ils font
comme travail beaucoup rêvent de faire
autre chose que ce qu'ils font mais bon
on se dit c'est pas facile de changer
et puis je me suis habitué à faire ce
que je fais et pis c'est pas facile non
plus de quitter la sécurité de son
salaire moi ça me rappelle l'histoire de
mon grand père lorsque j'étais enfant ma
grand mère me racontait comment il était
connu et respecté dans tout le quartier
car mon grand-père et des facteurs il
distribuait le courrier sur sa
bicyclette du temps de la colonisation
les gens disaient dalle facteurs un
facteur c'est un salarié il al'avantage
d'avoir un salaire régulier et c'est
bien ça la version en 1940 et 1950
d'intérieur brillante place pas un
travail stable avec un salaire régulier
une version qui a trop duré
surtout qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous
vivons plus longtemps donc nous
travaillons plus longtemps et puis
surtout nous voulons être heureux au
travail et sentir qu'on fait quelque
chose de vraiment important et pourtant
on continue à faire quelque chose qu'on
n'aime pas ou peut-être qu elle aimait
avant mais qu'on aime plus maintenant et
ma question pour vous et qu'est-ce que
vous aimeraient faire
kelly votre super pouvoirs cette chose
en laquelle vous êtes naturellement banc
en quoi êtes-vous naturellement banc et
peut-être que vous n'avez pas pensé à en
faire une carrière parce que personne ne
vous paye pour le faire
alors c'est cela l'idée que je viens
partager avec vous aujourd'hui on a tous
quelque chose qu'on aime faire un super
pouvoir
et l'idée c'est que on a souvent
tendance qu'en réfléchissant on va
arriver à décider et pourtant lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un changement de carrière c'est
différent on ne va rien trouvé en
réfléchissant on va trouver par l'action
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un changement de
carrière pour changer de travail
il faut plutôt agir que réfléchir
trois ans en arrière lorsque j'ai
commencé ma carrière de coach donc
d'abord ce changement de carrière qui a
eu lieu dans ma vie j'ai a eu lieu après
16 ans donc une saison de service comme
enseignante à l'université de la manouba
j'ai changé ensuite vers une nouvelle
carrière de coach
donc après 16 ans de travail est clos au
mur comme on dit chez nous monsieur
mérite
j'ai changé après 16 ans de service vers
une nouvelle carrière de coach qui aide
les gens à découvrir leurs forces pour
vivre la vie et la carrière dont il rêve
et j'ai douze minutes aujourd'hui pour
vous expliquer comment j'ai fini par
faire ce choix alors les trois dernières
années de ma vie ont été très
mouvementée j'ai déménagé trois fois
j'ai écrit le livre je n'ai publié qu'en
et ensuite
ensuite j'ai quitté la fonction publique
et je me suis lancé dans
l'entrepreneuriat mais avant ces trois
années ma vie était complètement
différente calme et stable avec la
sécurité d'un salaire régulier j'ai
laisser tout ça de côté et aujourd'hui
je travaille avec des entreprises
tunisiennes des multinationales et aussi
avec les instances de
et pas pour qui je fais coaching et
formation
et ce n'est pas du travail enfin pour
moi ce n'est pas du travail car j'adore
faire ça
j'aime faire ça mais eux
alors j'ai dit que voilà
même si on aime faire ça il faut il faut
quand même rappeler sa travail parce que
sinon vous paye pas et pour changer de
carrière donc pour changer de
trajectoire je n'ai pas beaucoup
réfléchi il faut dire j'y réfléchissais
même pas c'était pas sur mon plan de
carrière puisque je n'avais pas de plan
de carrière ni de vision pour l'ami pour
ma vie j'avais connu une période une
période où c'était pas la joie
une période de tristesse une période de
dépression et donc le psy et les
antidépresseurs c'était trop cher pour
moi vu les crédits et les engagements
alors je suis allé chercher des
solutions sur internet et c'est comme ça
que j'ai découvert la psychologie
positive et le développement personnel
et ensuite le coaching je me former et
plus je me former et plus j'avais
l'impression que je connaissais rien du
tout et plus de formation je suivais je
me suis rendu compte que j'avais ces
outils qui me permet maintenant nous
devons sortir de la dépression
ensuite j'ai vu autour de moi et j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait des personnes qui
avaient besoin de ces mêmes outils
alors j'ai partagé avec eux chez moi
dans mon salon
alors on m'a dit qu'il y a plus de
personnes qui ont besoin de ces mêmes
outils
alors nous avons organisé un atelier
ensuite des ateliers jusqu'à ce que je
sois devenu la personne que je suis
devenu aujourd'hui et c'est comme ça
qu'une nouvelle carrière a commencé pour
moi sans que je me rends compte que
c'est une nouvelle carrière
ensuite bien sûr
j'ai testé la température de l'eau j'ai
commencé à prendre conscience des
résultats que j'obtenais comme comme un
email que je reçois ou joly vous avez
été choisi pour conduire nos actions de
formation annuel mais s'il vous plaît
envoyez nous votre cv ça se passe à la
verse et j'ai compris comme ça qu'on ne
me choisissez pas pour mon cv ou pour
mes qualifications mais pour les
résultats que les personnes qui
travaillent avec moi
obtenez et c'est ce qui m'a donné la
confiance de me tenir devant ces deux
choix rester dans l'enseignement dans la
fonction publique
me dire que je vais garder un toit trop
bas pour mes ambitions ou quitter la
fonction publique
largués les voiles et à tous grands
sacrifices de grandes récompenses et jeu
et je découvre que tout ce temps que
j'avais passé à réfléchir qu'est ce que
je suis censé faire de ma vie ne servait
à rien la vérité même dora
l'exploratrice personnage de dessin
animé dora l'exploratrice a trouvé la
réponse avant moi il suffit de découvrir
il suffit d'accumuler les expériences
des apprentissages les découvertes et
tout mettre dans son sac à dos et
continuer à avancer
et puis vous savez c'est comme dans les
histoires d'amour un jour vous allez
savoir
lorsque c'est le vent on ne sait quand
c'est le bon choix de carrière ça vous
donne des ailes et vous vous dites c'est
ça c'est ce que je veux faire un
changement de carrière comme j'ai dit ça
se fait pas par la réflexion mais
seulement par une action et beaucoup de
personnes me disent jeunesse hassan ok
mais bon ce n'est pas ça je sais ce que
je veux c'est clair pour moi mais j'ai
peur alors dix mois plus tôt
comment tu as fait pour
crasé la peur et faire ce que tu as fait
voici écrasé la peur je suis morte de
peur j'en tremble encore mais voilà ce
que j'ai fait et pour cette partie vous
allez m'aider
vous allez m'aider alors on va tous
respirer un bon coup
fermez les yeux
imaginez imaginez que votre peur est ici
dans cet espace imaginez que votre peur
est présente
imaginez que votre peur est assise juste
à côté de vous votre peur est assise à
votre droite
dans quelques instants
vous allez regarder votre peur et lui
dire qui a deux choix où tu restes ici
où tu viens avec moi mais je ne
m'arrêterai pas tu as deux fois où tu
restes ici ou du viens avec moi mais je
ne m'arrêterai pas allez-y c'est à vous
génial bravo applaudissez vous
bravo mais c'est vrai que de toutes les
manières la peur est là et elle sera là
et elle n'est pas là pour nous empêcher
d'agir ou pour nous arrêter
mais elle est là pour nous prévenir que
nous sommes en train de nous aventurer
sur un terrain nouveau
nous sommes sur le point de faire
quelque chose de vraiment important mais
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on envisage un
changement de carrière il y a deux types
de peur auxquels nous serons confrontés
la première est la peur de perdre sa
stabilité
alors je vais sur twitter et je pose
cette question qu'est ce qu'un
changement de carrière pour vous ensuite
j'ai lu plusieurs commentaires comme un
aventure dans l'inconnu nouvelle vie il
ya vu une réponse qui se répétaient
risques et sa stabilité
et je me suis demandé si cette peur de
la stabilité je me suis demandé si elle
est réelle car je sais pas si comme moi
vous avez été un jour à cet endroit où
vous ressentez que vous avez tellement
plus à donner
vous avez accompli des choses vous êtes
en train de donner mais il y à cette
partie de vous qui restent dans l'ombre
inconnue elle n'a pas été découverte et
vous vous dites je pourrais faire plus
je pourrais faire mieux mais j'ai peur
de perdre la stabilité car comme dans
l'histoire de mon grand-père cette même
perception de la stabilité du travail
elle a persisté alors pendant les années
80 pendant les années 80 les personnes
qui qui n'avait pas les qualifications
pour obtenir un travail avec un salaire
régulier en tout cas dans ma famille ces
personnes là elles sont vraiment galéré
se sont mariés sans apporter d'or ou de
bijoux à leur femme certaines de mes
tantes en carrément fait objet de mots
cris par leurs autres par leur autre
cousine car elles se sont mariées sans
talent sont salle à manger sans
coiffeuse
les deux prétendants à mes tantes
n'était ni salarié ni fonctionnaire là
et emma sans l'autre apprenti forgeron
et mon grand-père avait consenti de mari
et ses deux filles aux deux hommes pour
deux raisons les deux étaient
travailleurs et n'avait pas d'addiction
à l'alcool ou à la cigarette
ce sont ces deux mêmes personnes qui
quelques années plus tard sont devenus
les industriels qui possède les plus
grandes usines de la région et sont
devenus millionnaires alors il serait
peut-être temps de changer cette
question autour de la stabilité par une
autre question suis-je en train
d'avancer
suis-je en train de développer mon
potentiel suis-je en train de vivre la
vie que je veux vivre et les deuxièmes
peur maintenant c'est la peur des
jugements des autres alors comme
beaucoup de personnes
j'ai connu toutes sortes de jugement sur
mes capacités
il faut dire que je viens d'une famille
où on passe d'une année à une année avec
15 de moyenne au minimum moi j'ai passé
avec 10 quand je passais alors malgré
les encouragements de mes parents j'ai
été jugé par les gens autour de nous
comme celle qui qui fait éloigner le
mauvais sort périphérie
oui et puis on disait heureusement que
c'est une fille elle ira chez son mari
pour une fille de 15 ans entendre
qu'elle n'a d'avenir que se marier est
restée à la maison est dévastateur
aujourd'hui je sais que ces jugements
n'ont aucun fondement car l'amour de
l'apprentissage et de la connaissance
julie dans mon adn
à tel point que j'ai décidé d'en faire
ma carrière aujourd'hui je sais que
l'opinion que quelqu'un d'autre a deux
mois n'est pas une vérité et n'a pas à
devenir ma vérité mais à l'époque je ne
savais pas et ça me limiter aujourd'hui
je sais que les autres juges de toutes
les manières et que plus on doute de
nous mêmes et plus on a peur d'être jugé
est plus 120 attirer des personnes qui
vont dire tu vas pas pouvoir faire ça
c'est impossible
rodez sont sur terre tu vas pas y
arriver alors vous avez le choix
plaire à tout le monde et ce n'est
jamais gagnée ou pour suivre vos rêves
et si vous décidez de suivre le chemin
de vos rêves vous allez avoir besoin de
construire un nouveau réseau de
personnes qui avancent avec vous ou
venez rejoindre notre communauté
vous y trouverez des gens qui vous
encouragent et encourage votre progrès
et pour finir je vais vous laisser avec
cette citation à jour votre vie va
passer comme un flash devant vos yeux
faites en sorte qu'elle mérite d'être
regardée
[Applaudissements]
et voici une question pour vous si tout
était possible pour vous que ferez vous
croyez fort en vous même viser les
étoiles
et n'oubliez pas de demander à dieu aide
et direction et commencer maintenant
merci
[Applaudissements]